una crisis que se alimenta de otra
mientras continúa el bombardeo ruso a
ucrania los mercados de materias primas
amenazan con agravar la tendencia
inflacionaria mundial
rusia y ucrania son dos de las despensas
agrícolas más grandes del planeta
juntos concentran casi una tercera parte
de las exportaciones de trigo una quinta
parte de las de maíz y un 80% de las de
aceite de girasol que compite con el muy
demandado aceite de soya como
consecuencia de la guerra millones de
toneladas de trigo ucraniano para la
exportación se encuentran bloqueados a
medida que rusia aumenta sus bombardeos
sobre las ciudades portuarias
pero el peligro es todavía mayor para
las naciones de áfrica del norte y
oriente medio cuya alimentación básica
depende en gran medida del trigo
ucraniano y ruso pero el aumento de
precios no sólo lo sentirán los
ciudadanos en sus mesas la cotización
internacional del petróleo y aarón da
los 100 dólares por barril un nivel al
que no llegaba desde 2014 que pone más
presión sobre el resto de la canasta
básica
[Música]
claramente los precios del petróleo y
los precios de la gasolina suben debido
a la crisis eso va a generar grandes
problemas en términos de la cadena de
suministro especialmente con la
interrupción de los puertos en el mar
negro y el impacto en las sanciones el
salto de los precios de las materias
primas no llega en el mejor momento pues
añade combustible a una crisis económica
que ya había traído la pandemia del cobi